many work all day others help
outside and inside the home no matter
what the situation is they take care of their
family and make sure they don't lack anything
if they parents come with me to
learn the story of andrés gonzález
below
my full name is german  andrés
gonzález all the fortune of the young father
well young if you can float life a
little but but when my
first daughter came into my life she was 29 years old
indescribable to be able to say when you
see your son come out of your
wife's womb and to be able to receive him and be able to  hug
and be able to look at each one of their little fingers and
each part of their body and know that it is
yours that it does not belong to anyone else that nobody
is going to take it from you that it is yours then it is
a very beautiful feeling and it becomes
difficult when you are a father  because
you don't know there isn't a manual that tells you
how to be a father or how to react to
different things types of ages in which
in a certain one you are a teacher in
another you are a person who has to  ue to
be a guide in another you have to be a
friend so they are things that one is
not taught or raised and this world does not come
and ok dad and how do I do it
I am fortunate that they
are both good students my daughter studies
in the technical academy here the treasure has
already entered to make zinc me and my youngest daughter is
already going to be
first meant in front of the same cage
so it gives me a little
peace of mind of comfort to start
because they are on the right path
thank god it does not try  of teaching by
example, that is, how am I going to
demand that my daughter be a worker if I
am not, or how am I going to teach my daughter
to read a book if I don't read it, how can I
raise my daughter to do  sports if
I don't do sports then I think
you have to create by example I get
up at half past one in the morning
to be at work at half past two
then well then I finish as
work schedule and I'm arriving here at  the house
at 11 11 and a half then what happens
at 11:30 a.m. for lunch, first he
asked, well, what do you want to eat or what
did the ipad always call your mother, it's the
mother, she tells me, well now we have to
make a menu and I have several things on the
menu my daughter I tell her it's not  for
bragging but my daughter makes the best
tomato soup the tomato cream that exists
in the world so that's what
we believe with her because she already loves to cook and she
's a good cook so
we find like like
like that dumbbell of saying well
then I study  I'm in charge of the other
stuff, I cook this, then I get
there, I cook right after I cook, well, I'll see if I have
to pick up something here at the house, clean,
take out the dog,
if you take a person for good,
you do your part, I'm like I told you
I am very affectionate I hug you
I love you very much my love I love you and 20 but
I am also very I am also strong because
I feel that if one does not place that
strong part then things do not get done
but it is very difficult the father is not
f  It's easy for them to do things with love
when things are done with love and
affection, I know that it will turn out well,
one has peace of mind as a father, to
say that one gave what he could give
to be me, they write and be someone
in  life reported for them I swim in
Spanish
natalia lanzelotti